liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
donald trump ist immer noch präsident
großbritannien ist immer noch in der eu
und an die steuer ist immer noch
verkehrsminister
ich würde 2009/10 gerne zurückgeben es
entspricht nicht meinen erwartungen
wenigstens starten wir das neue jahr mit
zwei frischen spd-vorsitzenden das ist
doch mal motivierend klar spätestens im
sommer landen die im unterirdischen
endlager der abgesägten spd-chefs aber
bis dahin alles gute
allerdings habe die namen schon wieder
vergessen
ein historischer fehler muss 2020 aber
korrigiert werden
na gut boris johnson ist britischer
premier und ak verteidigungsministerin
geschenkt aber warum ist florian
silbereisen der neue traumschiff
-kapitän carola rakete wird vom schiff
mac verhaftet und silbereisen darf das
tun sie fahren wollt ihr mich verarschen
ich wollte schiffskapitän sei dank das
zdf
und wer hat mal wieder gar keinen posten
abgetreten
fritzl märz der trottel vergeigt
wirklich jeden putschversuch leute 2020
muss merz vorsitzender werden von
irgendwas wenn sie einen posten im
vorsitz frei haben und wenn es nur ein
kleingartenverein ist ein krieger oder
ein swingerclub melden sie sich bitte
vorsitz für fritsch danke
war das ein schönes jubiläum 30 jahre
mauerfall
passend zum sieg der freiheit und
demokratie wählen die menschen in
thüringen brandenburg und sachsen die
afg auf platz zwei ich habe an jedem
wahlabend begeistert zwei flaschen
rotkäppchen-sekt gekauft und dann was
anderes getrunken für mich übrigens der
mann des jahres an die steuer sein pusch
bei der pkw-maut kostet uns eine halbe
milliarde
er findet ein generelles tempolimit ist
gegen jeden menschenverstand und er hat
das rentenproblem gelöst durch seine
bahnbrechende idee auf deutschen straßen
e roller für besoffene spanische
touristen zuzulassen werden große teile
der stadtbevölkerung das rentenalter
nicht mehr erleben
ok es macht tierisch spaß bergab hab ich
so ein ding schon mal auf 45 sachen
gekriegt weiß gar nicht mehr warum ich
da nackt war
ich habe nur einen vorsatz für 2020 ich
werde meine freunde treffen nicht mit
dem ziel sowohl
hans de schreibt über die heute show ihr
seid die richtigen links [ __ ]
besonders welke die stradivari unter den
arschgeigen bei euch smileys
freudentränen freudentränen
freudentränen freund rennkurs mit herz
vielen dank für ihr freundliches flugweg
für ein exklusives geigensolo von oliver
welke
abonnieren sie den kanal